My dad was a general surgeon in Egypt.
I was fascinated by what he did.
And then my aunt, his sister died in her early 20s from a heart disease...
...and I saw this happen and how he was upset for years.
And I declared I wanted to be a heart surgeon.
I started the journey in Egypt where I studied medicine...
...but immediately after that, I came to the United Kingdom...
...because I was convinced that was the place I wanted to practice in.
I liked very much the system of the National Health Service because it was egalitarian.
You strive for giving the best to everybody.
And I think that's really important and it is a model for the rest of the world to follow.
I think the National Health Service speaks loads about the character of the British people.
The National Health Service provides a very good model...
...for making health care at the highest level achievable for those who need it.
We are sitting now in the Magdi Yacoub Institute.